DC is hosting a special cosplay meetup
at New York Comic Con for everyone
dressed as one of the nightmare Batman
from Dark Knight's metal we've got pro
cosplayer here super X Luigi to give us
some hot tips on how to build your own
costume hi this is Super X Luigi and I'm
here to break down the nightmare Batman
costumes for the special cosplay meet up
at New York Comic Con so first I'm gonna
go over the nightmare Batman Green
Lantern kal what I did with this is I
found a template online to make a bat
cowl and I made this out of EB a foam
which is really cheap and pretty easy to
find you can find it at any hobby store
I used 5 millimeter and 2 millimeter
foam what I did is they come in sheets
and I used an exacto knife and traced my
pattern and cut them out and then I hot
glued them little by little each each
piece together to shape the bat cowl and
then after shaping it if you have a lot
of like seams that you want to get rid
of so I used a thinner piece of foam to
hide the seams and then I actually used
window and door sealant to hide the
seams even more and then after that I
got the goggles and I used contact
cement to put those in after you put the
cowl together
you want to use plastidip plastidip will
give it a plastic texture and you want
to do two to three coats of that and
then after that you want to find a
metallic spray because it's metal you
want to find a metallic spray I use
midnight black and I spray painted this
and then used a high gloss sealer to
give it that really metallic feel so
once you have the bodysuit you can then
add foam pieces to give it that metallic
feel so for the top part of the Green
Lantern Batman build a foam armor out of
foam and you can get thicker foam so I
would use a thicker foam then I used for
the back cowl and then for the utility
belt you can actually find a lot of
belts on Amazon or costume stores and
then repaint them to make them how you
want them for your costume and then for
the bracers I would use worbla
and it's going to give it a very
metallic look worbla is a thermoplastic
and it heats up very nicely and stays in
a shape
the only problem with worbla is it can
be hard to find so if you can't find any
war blood you can use EBA foam again and
attach it with Velcro and what's your
what you want to do with either the
worbla or the EBA foam is you want to
definitely use that pasta tip to give it
that nice base and then afterwards you
want to spray it with a metallic spray
paint to make it have that metal
nightmare Batman filled now you already
want to have the Batman symbol on your
costume but the Green Lantern symbol you
don't want to have it on there yet
because you want to make that yourself
you want to get the Green Lantern symbol
and trace it on foam cut out the foam
and put it over on your chest and you
can either attach it by sewing it or
with fabric adhesive so one of the most
important features of Green Lantern is
his reign because he's not Green Lantern
without his reign and where did I get my
ring no other than DC collectibles now
to make this ring pop out even more if
you get a green LED light and put it in
through the ring and you have a battery
pack on your hand you can turn on the
ring and have it so the nightmare Batman
Green Lantern has some piping coming
from the helmet you can find that at a
hardware store what I would do with that
is I would attach it to the helmet with
either hot glue or contact cement and
then to attach it to the suit I would
use velcro sewing in the velcro into our
bodysuit and that way it stays in place
so our nightmare Batman has kneepads now
how are we going to do that we were
they're gonna use worbla or EBA fo and
we are going to attach those to our
knees with Velcro they're gonna sew the
velcro into the bodysuit and then have
the other side of the velcro adhesive on
the knee pad and once you're done with
the kneepads you want to plastidip them
and then spray-paint them
metallic color so this concludes our
evil Batman tutorial this is just one of
the many Batman that you can build so
get out there and get crafting and we'll
see you guys at New York Comic Con that
gives you a head start on how to build
your own evil Batman cosplay so get to
work so you can be ready for the meet up
at New York Comic Con plus don't forget
Harley Quinn is taking over Batman day
for her 25th anniversary so for more
details on that head on over to DC
Comics comm flash Batman day we'll see
you tomorrow